[Music]
my quarantine fat of choice this last
summer
was gardening among other things i was
working with some basil
and a friend of mine sent me a recipe
for pesto
turns out they're one of those good at
cooking types so
instead of talking tablespoons or cups
this recipe was all in grams
seeing that i don't own a scale i
realized that i had stumbled upon
a totally real world definitely not
contrived
need for machine learning i know how
tall the plants are
what species they are and some other
yada yada about the concentration of
some sort of chemical
and i need to estimate my basal mass
thankfully the previous tenant of 10
years has been collecting measurements
on this same plot
so i have some solid data to work with
so what's our strategy
maybe there's no need for anything fancy
we could start out with a linear
regression
or maybe i'm the kind of feller that
uses knn in the regression setting
we could run with that or maybe i'm
feeling trendy and decide that my best
move is a neural network
or okay hear me out what if i could
figure out some way
to combine those outputs i want to come
up with some sort of model that
generates predictions that are informed
by each of these constituent models
this is the premise behind ensembling
ensembling is a machine learning
technique that has been shown to
increase predictive performance in a
variety of settings
in a community survey conducted over the
summer by the tidy models team we
learned that users felt that the number
one priority for future development in
this ecosystem
should be ensembling this december we
are delighted to announce the initial
release of stacks
a package for tidy models aligned model
ensembling
when you're coding up an ensemble with
stacks most of the code you'll end up
writing isn't specific to stacks at all
i'll skip over the code that generates
these models but the gist is that i've
created three model specifications here
using functionality from the tidy models
core packages like parsnip
workflows recipes in tune
the linear regression spec here just
defines one model definition
there aren't any hyper parameters to
tune for this k n model spec
though i'm tuning over several possible
numbers of neighbors so the spec
actually defines four model definitions
finally for this neural network model
i'm tuning over six combinations of
numbers of hidden layers and dropout
rates
so the spec defines six model
definitions
in stacks each of these 11 model
definitions are called candidate members
or candidates for short
these candidates are the building blocks
for an ensemble
the first step to putting together a
model stack is the stacks initialization
function
which works kind of like the ggplot
function from ggplot2
it lays the foundation called a data
stack for the model to be built on top
of now the first core of urban stacks
is add candidates it takes in a
candidate and
adds it we can iteratively call the
function as many times as we need to
to add all the candidates under the hood
ad candidates collects predictions on a
subset of the training data from each
candidate
and appends them as columns to the data
stack
the second core verb is blend
predictions which fits a regularized
linear model
on the data stack predicting the true
outcome using the predictions from each
of the candidate members
we call the coefficients of this linear
model stacking coefficients
a stacking coefficient of 0 means that
the predictions for the relevant
candidate
will not ultimately influence the model
stack's predictions
candidate members with non-zero stacking
coefficients earn the title of members
and we can fit them on the whole
training data using the fit members
function
and that's it the output if it members
is ready to predict on new data
fingers crossed that i'll nail this
pesto recipe
you